you know there's this misconception that
people think great leaders great
entrepreneurs great creative people are
this larger-than-life personality
charismatic you know just when they come
and they light up the room but today I'm
gonna make a case to you introverts out
there why some of the possible greatest
entrepreneurs and thinkers were
introverts all right so let's get right
into so introverts if you're an
introvert today it's all about you and I
know introverts love attention they love
compliments they love it when we give
them all the attention don't it as a
matter of fact what they don't like is
introverts kind of want to be left alone
a little bit but let's dissect how
introverts are from my experiences as
well as reading some papers on this
number one they have zero problem with
other egos coexisting with them very
comfortable they can work in an
environment and people with big
personalities big big egos massive egos
have a very comfortable time working
with them Wozniak worked with jobs Jobs
had a massive personality Wozniak was an
introvert but it worked out very well
number two they lead from back when you
leap from back they allow other leaders
to be developed which means for them
leadership development which is a big
part of building big company comes very
easy because so many people get the
credit when they're working around them
they don't need all the credit so when
this happens people's identity around
them is always elevating when you work
with an introvert number three they're
comfortable being alone and this edge
that they have on being comfortable
being alone allows them to be patient
calm and focus more because a lot of
time when you start a business or your
sales person if you can't be comfortable
being alone you can't do proper research
you can't be focused on your next
project you sometimes overwhelm yourself
with non-existing issues where they're
okay in that area because they enjoyed
their own company number four great
listeners which means they ask the right
questions and if the answer right
questions they end up solving the right
problem that optimizes the chances of
increasing the company so it's the right
questions they ask that leads to the
right answers now
five they do well with extraversion
you're gonna want to do what would
extroverts introverts have no problem
doing well with them because to them
they look at extroverts and saying oh
wow I can never be like that person it'd
be great to team up with them that's how
they look at it if I can team up with an
extra they're very because people can
coexist with them they have an easy time
doing good with extra verse this is why
the end of finding people like jobs six
more logical which means they're
rational which means risk is not like
the crazy biggest risk they'll take
there'll be a little bit more methodical
about their next move they're making
because they're rational logical the
better thinkers typically these
introverts number seven since they're
not the center of attention they see
thinks others don't
meaning body language so imagine you're
sitting in a room and introverts are
typically just kind of sitting there
quiet they're not really talking saying
anything everybody else is talking
pitching their ideas all this other
stuff and 95% of the time they're not
doing anything and when they are talking
they're typically asking a question so
guess what they learn they officially
learned about everybody in a room seven
people gave answers they learned who
doesn't like ooh they learned who's
trying to get what from who they learn
who's the most influential person here
they learn who's full of it they learn
who's not respect in the room but they
learn about everything in the room
because they see things that others
don't see because they do not need to be
the center of attention number eight
they're more trusting anytime you deal
with an introvert you typically trust
them more so it's easier to raise money
easier to sell something easier to get
people to want to team up with you
because you're trusting number-9 overly
prepared because they look at things and
say we know what if that happens or what
if this happens and what if that happens
and what if this happens what if this
happens okay great
as long as I have this kind of stuff in
place because they don't like to be
humiliated because they are overly
prepared great
I'm scored away because they're
typically over prepared all right so
last but not least they're also very
self motivated because they sit there
once they get clear on what they want to
do they may be a little bit more
technical they may be a little bit
slower on making their decisions but
what once they do you don't need to
motivate them they're gonna figure out a
way to get the job done because they
don't want being alone to solve problems
they're pretty logical and rational on
the next step process they come up with
and they're typically self motivate so
having said that today's episode was two
introverts if you're watching this and
you're an introvert yes this is you and
you have a very
high chance of winning because you're in
great community with people like gates
Einstein Zack Buffett musk soos George
Washington and many other names so
today's episode was for you but if
you're type A personality and you're
wondering how you're wired here's a
video I did for you guys I don't know
six months ago twelve months ago if
you've never watched a click over here
and a video I've made four or five years
ago on four different personality types
and how to work with them that link is
over here click on this one to watching
it if you've not yet subscribed to this
channel please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care of a bite
[Music]